alors catherine au moins de novembre
donc le chatelier avec combien de
musiciens sur scène alors qu'elle
symphonique orchestra qui se compose de
40 musiciens et je les mets sur scène
ouais ce que j'ai toujours j'ai été
musicienne de faux orchestre et on
souffre de ça et je pense que c'est
dommage de s'offrir 40 musiciens et des
mines dans une fosse ouais si le nom en
pleine lumière pour moi je vais les
mettre dans une vraie les médecins
ouais et ça s'appelle comment ça
s'appelle sans délai romantique c'est
une évocation des futurs g/100 g
alors tu sais que les gens ne manqueront
pas de jahvé sur le fait que tu
t'intéresses genre jeu semble quand même
non jazz et pourquoi pas ce que tu as
déclaré chez denisot oui
denise haute a demandé quand il faut
regarder d'abord chez zen voilà tu as
répondu sa femme excellent meilleure
réplique que j'entendais depuis
longtemps pour voir un peu sans son
regard d'un homme quand on veut le
connaître mais on veut regarder ça et
puis on peut aussi regarder simplement
parce qu'elle est belle et candidats les
uns donc pourquoi pas donc maintenant
enfin je veux dire c'est pas grave mais
tu avoues que j'aime bien les femmes
quoi
j'aime bien les êtres ouais mais je
crois qu'il faut pas se cacher il faut
pas avoir de tabou il faut mais là il
faut vivre ça et que sourire les gens
m'attire il ya des hommes que je trouve
intéressant il y avait donc que je
trouve intéressante mais aucune
frontière dans ma vie dans ma sensualité
nez dans mes amours certaines personnes
assument leurs fantasmes et d'autres pas
oui moi je fais partie des gens qui
les assumer ça évite l'aigreur c'est à
dire de bien valider le prix spécial air
de faire du bien oui ben oui oui tu as
pris conscience à quel âge que tu es
mais aussi les femmes et toutes petites
mains ah bon oui c'est vrai qu'elle a
ajouté trois en quatre ans un bon petit
jeu je veux rester comme ça j'étais
fasciné par les gens et au début ça t'a
culpabiliser tu disais non mais du tout
même si tu t'es jamais dit tu t'es
jamais dit c'est bizarre je suis attiré
par les femmes non non parce que j'ai
toujours aimé ce qu était un peu
interdit
ouais c'était le côté belle aventure
ouais et aujourd'hui alors je veux dire
que j'ai pu je fréquente des hommes des
femmes ou seulement des femmes il est
vrai qu'il ya des gens qui je fais la
cour et d'autres qui je fais jardin ça
dépend des fois on trouvait là qu au
jardin - a finalement un os la cour la
cour est alors je sens dans tout ça
qu'est ce que le comment elle vivait sa
george sand george sand et une
principalement une femme homme et une
femme qui aimait les hommes toute sa vie
et qui a eu quelques attirance pour une
marie dorval par exemple était une
comédienne qui était un petit peu ce
qu'ils veulent adjani d'époque mari
ça dans sa vie mais je crois que c'était
elle a vécu ses attirances et ses amours
le plus honnêtement possible c'est une
femme très honnête qui a vécu sa vie
affective sa vie sa vie d'écrivain je
trouve c'est un exemple pour moi
alors imagine qu aujourd'hui une jeune
fille qui regardent cette émission et
qu'ils soient qu'ils jeunes qui ces
paquets dans un milieu un peu style à
tout ça et qu'ils soient tentés par par
les femmes plus dû à quoi
non il faut vivre les expériences qu'on
a envie de vivre il faut surtout vive
les choses avec le choeur avec le pu se
permettre
vulgairement